you know nothing could be
more fitting or more satisfying than
having michael do the introduction
because the whole point of being a
teacher
is seeing what happens in future
generations and the fact that i was able
to teach him when he was an
undergraduate here
and now he's taking over right it's just
a a great thing to see happening
so
as michael pointed out the
motivation i had to put together this
particular talk
was the
award speech for the research
achievement award at kai a couple years
ago
and what that gave me is
license to sort of look back right
usually you give a talk and it's here's
the latest stuff that's going on
but then when you get old enough and
gray enough you get the license to say
hey look at all this and it was really
fun putting it all together because
it really made me aware of how much
great work had been done over the years
in hci i mean
a lot of the stuff that seems really new
and fresh now you can go back and see
the roots of it 20 30 40 years ago
so
what you'll see here i collected up a
bunch of
pictures and stuff of the oldies but
goodies right i mean things that have
been around for a long time and still
have a lot of value
so
the structure i'm going to talk some
about
uh did i just
the the history but the context for that
is
looking at how things have progressed in
the
different dimensions that go into the
name kai and as you know
we here call it hci but the acm many
years ago created a special interest
group in chi question is our computers
first or people first
we believe people are first but that's
the way it's been uh it's a much
catchier acronym anyway
chi it's a greek letter hickey is the
wrong acronym right
um
so
there's computers
there's humans and there's the
interaction so i sort of started with
that as a framework for looking at what
went on so
um
assuming let's see i probably have to
get my cursor somewhere else
there we go
so how long have computers been around
all right and this is actually a test
for you grey hairs in the audience i'm
going to ask recognition who knows what
this is
okay lots of people somebody say
this is not babbage
um that's doran suede from the science
museum in london who
put together a working model of
the
babbage i think this is actually the
original engine not the more the fancier
one that he was trying to build
um but computing uh has been around in
some form or another for what has a
hundred and fifty hundred getting close
to 100 more well over 100 years
so the idea's been around but of course
it didn't take hold until we had
electronics
that could make something that was not
as cranky and hard to deal with as a big
bunch of gears
so test number two who's this
grace
who was one of the
primary movers in the use which was
actually an admiral in the navy uh of
computers this is now that in starting
world war ii when computers started to
be used in a very practical way of
course it always been used for these
kinds of purposes i mean the stuff
babies did was for calculating tides and
moving navies around and stuff but the
use of computers
became much more
effective and broader
this is a univac one of the early
computers and what's interesting is of
course in those days all computers were
personal right
you sat in front of the thing and you
pushed the buttons that's how you made
it run
so that was the original idea of
computers
i got into computers in
some sense
back in the
early 1960s
early early 1960s maybe even late 50s
with this computer
the guy with the short hair is actually
me
and this is my high school science
project
which was a
sort of hybrid digital analog computer
what the digital meant is these dials
actually had fixed positions and the
analog meant everything was done by
having a whole bunch of resistors that
you measured the currents on and they
came up on the dial and stuff
uh interesting point that i did this is
when i said my high school science
project went to the science fair
and the judges said gee that's really
cool but it's engineering not science
i think ces has been fighting that
question ever since right do we really
use science is it really computer
science or is it just just of course
that's a funny word uh engineering the
guy who won the science fair had a thing
where he took um
fruit flies and did some experiments on
them and stuff you know it's real
science
um
a few years later
we run that around that same time this
is what a computer looked like right so
the hardware had become much more
regularized much more industrialized it
sat behind glass windows in a big room
people
sat in and ran operations and
did all the stuff with those big tapes
and stuff
um my
first contact with digital computing was
a slightly different interface i wasn't
sitting in the big glass room uh how
many of you know what this thing is
okay have you ever used it and that's
the real gray hair test
that is the way you input and output
things to the computer was by taking
some kind of a material paper or in this
case mylar was actually used
and punching holes in it which could be
sensed and then feeding it into the
computer so when i started teaching here
in 73 the introductory programming class
punched decks of cards and took them
over to the computer center and
submitted them in a window and then a
while later we get a print out saying
that didn't work
and then they go back and do it again
and again first computer that i used
which i'll show you in a minute uh had
paper tape which was a somewhat well
just a different format but the same
basic idea
was this machine how many now who are
really test how many know what this
machine is
it might be a 1620
nope
so this is made by control data now your
first reaction is wait a minute i
thought control data made super
computers cray and all that kind of
stuff the answer is yes but in the early
days they did a variety of things
including the
64 640 number right
which was a personal computer this was
this actually the size factor here is
what it looks like this is a desk
right you put your knees under here you
got a console there you punch the
buttons on the console it has a paper
tape reader which you can see in the
upper right there
which takes in those reels of tape that
i mentioned and a paper tape printer
which actually came out the left hand
side here which printed out
punched out tape and the way you
interacted with that is something called
a flexo writer which was like a
typewriter that punched and read paper
tape so you'd type your stuff on the
flexor writer you'd run the tape in my
first experience with that i actually
had one of these at the college i went
to
during a special workshop there was no
such thing as computers and colleges in
those days it was a small college
and it was a very hot day and so in
order to keep the computer running they
had to put a fan behind it and of course
i managed almost immediately to run an
entire reel of paper tape directly into
the fan
um
so learning about atoms and bits from
from early era
from the point of view of my own sense
of human computer interaction i think
it's true these things have a big effect
the
important point about this was
it was my personal computer there's a
guy who got a position in the town i was
in
who had previously been in a bigger city
he came with this computer which he'd
gotten on a medical grant he was
actually calculating things for
radiation treatment of cancer
and
he called up the college and he said you
have any computer students and they said
computer what's that all right he said
well do you have any math students who
might be able to figure this thing out
so i got a job i would go over to the
hospital after school or at night and
sit in a room with this thing and
program okay and i didn't know anything
i mean literally i had to reinvent
uh assembly code in some sense because
all i had was the numerical machine
manual
um
but what it gave is the feeling that a
computer is not something that sits in a
glass cage and you submit decks to but a
computer is something you push the
buttons actually the repair person said
i don't know why this the buttons on
this computer always seem to break down
the answer is that's how i was
programming
i was much more effective than punching
tape so i could push all the buttons
this is a
more or less contemporaneous 60s
computer now i know some of you know who
this is
joe weisenbaum who was mit this is a
model 35 i believe teletype that he was
using which was the way you communicate
with computers one step better than
paper tape and punch
and i'm going to come back later to talk
about eliza and what he did with it
but when i got to mit now we're in the
mid 60s this was sort of the the state
of the art in what people were using in
computing you could interact with it by
typing on a teletype there were the
original time sharing systems have been
developed uh john mccarthy who
unfortunately died recently who was here
was one of the obviously the founders of
that and was at mit for a while
and
there was a chance for
people to have a direct immediate
interaction with the computer even
though they didn't have one dedicated to
themselves in a in a room in the
hospital
um
jumping ahead this is a bit later
okay and anybody who's gotten a degree
here in hci should recognize this one
okay
so this is the xerox alto this was the
beginning of the shift in how you think
of what a computer is
right it's the first graphics screen
that was done it was the first attempt
to
let you interact with a mouse and do
things on a personal computer i'll come
back to engelbart and mouse in a minute
um
and
in some sense everything we have done
since so we're now talking this was in
the early 80s those 30 plus years
has been variations on that theme
we're moving beyond we'll talk about
that but is that that's what
mid 70s sorry mid 70s yeah
so um this is uh
really what's interesting about this is
how stable this configuration this
wave-looking thing if you look at this
and you said this is something i bought
recently most people wouldn't know they
look a little weird but it's more or
less what you can still buy from dell
right it's
the same thing
not picky on dell just you know it's not
a tablet right it's it's
uh so i was at park actually uh with
danny barbara who's here and a number of
people for three years including alan
kaye who i'll talk about also uh and
they really had a whole
thrust actually
tomorrow night
probably not relevant to most of you but
at the computer history museum is having
their annual
honoring of new fellows
and one of those new fellows is bob
taylor
who was the head of the lab that that
did this at park uh and was really a
visionary back in those very early days
in the 70s and sort of moving from
the whole mainframe mentality to the
personal computer mentality he he wasn't
himself the guy who built it but he
really collected and pushed and made
resources to make it happen
at around the same time this guy was
doing work across town
who he is
was it sri which at the time was
stanford research institute and he had a
system they called augment
which were called nls at the time
various names but which enabled groups
of people to work together it was very
consciously a shared system not a
personal system the alto was personal
with networking this was really a shared
system and he invented all sorts of
things which again if you went to the
store today is not that different than
what he did so he is the original crew
you can't see in this picture very well
creator of the mouse
uh he actually thought his other
invention input invention was better and
was always somewhat frustrated that
people didn't pick up on it which was a
keyboard you can use with one hand
by hitting multiple keys at once
because his view was you wanted to keep
one hand on the mouse one hand on the
keyboard and not have to keep shifting
back and forth
right but turned out this was too hard
to use the mouse was really easy to use
it became the
the main source
this picture actually comes from an
event that was held in san francisco
back in 1967 which is known colloquially
as the mother of all demos
and it's really pretty impressive you
should look at the video
there's a youtube that you can get uh
look up engelbart or mother of all demos
or whatever
they set up a this is in a big hall in
san francisco a projector okay now today
the projector up there is you know okay
you put a few hundred bucks you get a
projector in those days it was an
incredible technical tour of force to
have a projector that could actually put
stuff on a screen in an auditorium from
a computer it involves writing in oil
and i mean all sorts of amazing stuff
he then set up a microwave link to
connect that to his lab back in menlo
park
which again today is nothing in those
days the idea that you could have a
computer in menlo park projecting on a
screen in san francisco was that's the
future
um he had a video conference so along
that link he was on video here um
somebody told me the name the
on the other end
no it wasn't bill
i'll get back to i remember right anyway
uh was it there and they were talking
as they were doing the typing so they
had they had skype
right it wasn't quite skype but
it was there but the whole that whole
texture that feel of what it's like to
compute on the network to type things in
have them show up on the screen this is
also interactive in the obvious way it
was an outliner so if you look up there
you'll see it's a grocery list
which you use for example and you could
add things and move them around and
reorder them and sort them and do all
the things which again today seem
completely
of course
in those days were just like amazing
that a computer could do those things it
wasn't what people thought about they
thought about computers as calculating
numbers right that's what they're good
at
at the same time at park and i'm a
little park centric because i think they
did amazing a lot of the early work in
all these areas uh i was not involved in
these particular projects but was around
and sort of seeing what went on uh who's
this
the guy with the suspenders
mark weiser
so he had a group of park that was
developing what they called ubiquitous
computing and his idea was you didn't
want to think of a computer as just that
thing on the desk but it should be all
different scales so he talked about
computing by the inch the foot and the
yard so computing by the inch was this
thing called the park tab which you see
up at the top
which wasn't quite as sophisticated as
an ipad or an iphone but
was the ancestor an eye tab i'm sorry
the i tab the ipad
and the
what was that
this wasn't called the eye wall it had
some other name any it wasn't called i
right sorry the park tab the park pad
and the
park
something
uh
but i believe but you know again when
you look at this and you say well isn't
it nice to have a tablet that you can
actually pick up and write on like a
tablet nice to have something up on the
wall that you can actually scribble on
with
markers and it knows that you're
scribbling
that's pretty much what people are using
i mean that's that's very much part of
today's culture this was now back in the
early 80s or mid to sorry late 80s for
wiser
um
so
the technology moved beyond the sort of
computer as a simple form factor to this
ubiquitous concept we did some work on
that here at stanford so this is
something called the eye room which is
just about 10 yards down the hall here
on your left
where we tried using multiple big
screens a table-based display
integrating it with some stuff on your
laptop could be combined with
the stuff that was on the screen
um
francois
gambit
who was a student who worked on how
could you have high resolution up close
interaction with complex visual
materials
so this is all part of that same
development and
going back to my sort of framework how
you rethink as you go along
what is the computer that you're using
now today you think about i phone size
things smart phones and so on so
obviously this has progressed but in
some sense those directions were set up
so i want to switch gears
and think about the second component
which is what is the human
and i'm posing this as that question
which is sort of an interesting way to
ask
what is it to be human well let's take a
first most obvious example
a human is a physical bunch of
protoplasm right a human is somebody who
has a certain figure a certain size a
certain shape
and this view of what it is to be human
actually played a big role in the early
development of what later became hci if
you go back to the literature on what's
called human factors
people realize and this is again
starting with machine human symbiosis
and essentially world war ii was when
this all became active
that if you were going to have people
use computers
accurately you needed to at least
conform to what people are you couldn't
build it too big too small too strong
whatever there was a whole field in of
world war ii research and human factors
which was basically looking at the human
from this sort of what are the human
physical capacities side this picture
actually is not from that era it's
slightly before
it's from work by henry dreyfus
who was a very early industrial designer
fascinating guy he
i have his book title in here somewhere
later but
who
actually started out in stage lighting
and things like that he was a designer
got into industrial design then got into
sort of industrial design from a use
perspective designed things like the
train from chicago to new york where he
was involved in everything from what it
looked like inside the train car is to
how did you get your tickets
so if you think about interaction design
he was doing he really was one of the
founders along with raymond lowe and
some other people of of what became
the design world the industrial design
later
on okay so it's clear that a person
among other things is a physical body if
you want to understand that
there are various fields that help you
understand it so human factors sort of
tries to condense the stuff from
physiology and physics and so on
what else is a human
okay who's this guy
alan turing right so alan turing among
many other things
is famous for having said i will believe
that a computer is like a person when it
can carry on a conversation with me
okay so this is now back in the 50s and
you've said this is the famous touring
test
the measure of humanness is the ability
to carry on not a necessarily verbal
conversation it can be type written but
a lit conversation in ordinary language
and this has become
over time of course in many ways a
measure of what's human so
who's that
how right for those of you who are young
and haven't seen it go see the movie
it's 2001
which is now long in the past but still
haven't quite gotten there yet
how was a
computer system on the spaceship
who interacted with natural language the
interesting thing about it is there was
no attempt at personification or robot
or anything how was this blinking light
but talked like a person
right and there was a very strong sense
that it was he was he and it's almost
impossible not to call him a he as
opposed because the voice was a male
voice
um
was
a person who sabotaged missions so on so
on there's a whole wonderful
plot that that went into that so a
second view is that
a person
what it means to be human is measured by
whether you can use language
okay now this was followed up by various
programs so i mentioned earlier joe
weisenbaum i showed you a picture of him
he wrote a program called eliza how many
of you have actually
interacted in some form with eliza or
the doctor
has different names right it's around
you should go find it on the web it's a
it's now the kind of thing you could
give a
freshman you know a couple hours to
program i mean it's not sophisticated by
today's standard but it was very scary
yeah right
so um
eliza let you type in things you type
back so you typed are you like my father
in some ways and eliza type back what
resemblance do you see
and it says you are not very aggressive
what makes you think i am not very
aggressive okay now what's interesting
about eliza and it's a really important
lesson for this whole question of what
it is to be a computer and a human is
it
showed beyond out the power of
projecting intelligence onto the things
we used
so
eliza was a really dumb program right so
for example it had it had rules that
scanned the text so if it saw the word
mother it said
tell me more about your family
so if you said something like my
friend's mother just died
it says tell me more about your family
now if there's a person you know you
would say that's crazy right
but
because i was pretending to be a
psychiatrist which was an incredibly
clever trick
your first thought was oh that's
interesting i'm sure my friend's mother
dying has evoked all sorts of feelings
in myself about my family and it's
really a smart thing to ask
right you
build in the intelligence you project
back the intelligence
because it's responding like a person a
lot of you here have taken classes from
or read books by cliff nass and byron
reeves on what they call the media
equation and it makes that point in many
many ways that when we interact with a
device which in even the slightest sense
is person-like we make it much more
person-like in the way we react to it
and so probably from an evolutionary
point of view a pretty good reaction
that we have which is to treat people
differently from the rest of the world
but it does do funny things in cases
like this so eliza was a great proof
that you don't need to really be
intelligent you don't need to really use
language to make people have the feeling
that you are
a little bit later i did a program which
got a lot of note called shirtleu this
is a picture from the screen
and it was based on work that was going
on at the mit ai lab which involved
trying to get computers to do really
simple things that kids can do so there
was vision trying to look at a scene
with a bunch of blocks and figure out
what's in it there was motor symbol
robot that was trying to move them
around and they were simple language
it was called it got called the blocks
world
and i took that as a basis for what
could you actually achieve in getting a
person in a computer to work together
using language so you would type in
something like pick up a big red block
and what you would see on the screen
notices before the days of hidden line
elimination and sophisticated graphics
uh what you would see on the screen was
that sort of crane-like thing come down
and move it around
okay the interesting thing about it was
two things i think that made it have a
significance one is that it was
integrated with a
model a logical model of what was on the
table it actually had a record of where
all these blocks and what color are they
and so on notice that the colors by the
way it's also before the date of color
screens their little says red here and
small letters
second is that in building it i was
paying attention to linguistic details
of things like context so one of the
most obvious points about human language
as opposed to formal languages
is that we only say the minimal part of
what we need to say given that we know
the other side is understanding so
consider a phrase like
pick up a bigger one
what does that mean what's a bigger one
bigger than what and so on well the
answer is obvious because you just said
pick up something and in fact i probably
mean the one you actually picked up
right so i pick up a bigger one it's a
lot bigger not than any particular one
but the one that
you just picked up and i built into the
program
a bunch of these sort of heuristics a
bunch of these rules which say when
somebody uses a pronoun or uses a word
like one or says do it again i mean all
these things that we just take for
granted
there is information in what's going on
in the past in the world and because
this had a complete
record of what it was doing in this
little toy world
it was able to come up with a response
that seemed way way more natural than
anything people have done with computers
i think now again let me
ping that you know remind you of the
projection question how much was it
really smarter and how much was it just
projecting on it but in any case it
really got people to thinking well
computers could be pretty smart in the
touring sense right in the sense of
making you feel like you're interacting
with a real person
i wrote a book on this which published i
actually originally by edinburgh
university press surprisingly enough
this is not the version that's around
mostly
i was working in the mit ai lab and
there's a couple in addition to the fact
that my hair was just as big but
different color
there's what you see up there on the
left anybody
any gray hairs on that one
deck 360 display
uh digital equipment corporation with
micro tapes okay a whole bunch of
interesting sort of technologies that
digital uh developed and it's or in its
heyday of being a real computer company
um
and this is marvin minsky who was the
head of the lab and
was looking at all these questions like
how could you have computers with arms
and and vision and so on this is an arm
he designed with the idea you don't need
to have the same joints people do
you need the same number of degrees of
freedom to get to where you want to go
and that maybe there are very different
ways of doing that he actually advised
he was a technical advisor for the 2001
movie on how you could you could do
things interesting ways
in today's world
um
this is still considered as language is
still considered a measure of
intelligence what is the question to
this answer
who is watson
right so
putting it in this perverted
jeopardy direction
there was a program that got a lot of
notice within the past couple years
because it defeated a human champion at
trivia questions
and i'm using trivia questions here in a
somewhat technical not pejorative sense
that is not questions like you know
what's the most important meaning of
whatever it's like what battle of and so
did such and such went in so questions
which can be answered with a fairly
straightforward application of direct
bits of knowledge that you can find
somewhere out in the digitized knowledge
of the world
right so i think we're very much still
in this sort of view that
being
human i mean here's a picture of him
who knows interesting i just had this
discussion with somebody about the fact
that ibm chose very consciously not to
make it a human-like face
right notice this could have been a
cartoon it could have been a picture of
a person instead they have this very
abstract icon
uh i think people would have very
different psychological reactions in a
way if they had
so let me move on we'll come back to
natural language if you want but the
basic point is that one of the things
that really categorizes people is their
ability to use language and of course
there's
a lot of study in linguistics a lot of
what i did was based on linguistics a
lot of what
watson does is based on linguistics and
what i'm doing with this right hand
column here is just pointing out that
hci is truly interdisciplinary
if you want to do research you want to
build things
the key is that you need to bring in all
of these different fields it's not like
there's just one that tells you what to
do
okay so here's another model of what the
brain is
what's his name
bubble head right so bubble head was a
conception of how people think that was
done by among others al newell and and
herb simon at carnegie mellon uh people
like tom moran who was at derek's park
actually everything all roads come back
to park
um
and the idea is in a way going back to
that dreyfus thing but in the head
so if a person is able to reach
three feet out but not four feet out
that tells you something about human
capacities
they said well that's also true for the
way you think
so
if i
do the most obvious experiment most of
you have done this but just for
completeness repeat after me 4302
was that your ability to do that is
extremely regular compared to most other
people it's not like you can remember
three and he can remember eight and he
can remember 12. there are a few
exceptions but within the great majority
everybody basically runs out of steam at
what number
seven plus or minus two okay it's the
name of his famous paper that is uh
we're just geared we're just built to be
able to
remember about seven numbers that's why
telephone numbers are about that long
among other things right
um it's not because we've used telephone
numbers that's why they built them that
way
so in the same sense that dreyfus could
talk about the physical characteristics
we can talk about the mental capacities
how much can you remember how long can
you remember it how well can you
perceive differences don norman who's
here did a lot of the early work in sort
of looking at a whole bunch of different
dimensions of
of these kinds of questions
so from this point of view a person is a
cognitive processor they have a
long-term memory a short-term memory
they have a set of algorithms for
going through data
and the obvious metaphor here is the
digital computer if i were to say here's
a computer and if you give it five
numbers it restores them when you give
it six it can't
you say ah it's got a five number
register
right the notion of a register of fixed
length is sort of just a natural thing
that flows out of a digital model of
storage and memory maybe there were
things like this that
were the same kind of digital
model so
another way of looking at it is that a
per a human is an information processor
this led to what's called information
processing psychology
was really the roots of a lot of what's
going on in hci um
here's a picture of
newell and simon who were the sort of
pioneers of this whole approach uh
at carnegie the one of the things they
studied was how people played chess
which was a great example of a kind of
cognitive
process that the people could use
so this is the mental version of the
human factors dimension it says there's
cognitive psychology which can give us
all sorts of insights into the human
thinking of the human as a
finite fixed capacity memory prior
information processor
and for many years this was a dominant
paradigm in
psychology i think it's still a very
active one although i think a lot of the
more
explicitly neurological stuff has become
much more the sort of things that people
focus on now
but they're combined right when you look
at neurons you're still often thinking
of them as how do they function as a
limited capacity memory limited capacity
information processing device
okay
back to
the sky
you can see in the picture
doug eaglebart okay so this is silicon
valley before the current dress code
uh where
all the engineers were white shirts and
narrow ties
data by the width of the ties
and he said i don't
think of people as these isolated
entities that have brains and talk and
so on i think of them as communities i
think of them as people who work
together and what i want to do is
augment their ability to work together
better
so he created among other things that
demo that i talked about earlier uh the
nls system and his whole point was how
do you facilitate this kind of
interaction
i can remember very clearly when i was a
graduate student at mit in the ai lab
that i showed you marvin minsky and
engelbart came and gave a talk this is
late 60s
and the general reaction was
that's really stupid why would you want
a computer to help you type things when
you can make it smart
if you're not making the computer be
intelligent you're wasting the
computer's time to just you know put
things on screens and type them and
communicate them and that kind of stuff
that we can do that on paper
so i think that was a blindness i think
it was a blindness within the ai
community that said
the only interesting use of computers
the only interesting way in which
they're like people or they're useful
for people is to make them be smart so
engelbart had a very different uh take
on that and that led into the whole
field which is often called
computer-supported cooperative work
uh that a person is somebody in a group
and i said hey a worker in an
organization clearly that's what he
thought i mean he was not looking at
social networks and people with their
friends and so on but the whole world of
looking at the computer as a
communication device between people who
are getting things done together
grew out of this sort of focus on
uh on that there is a bunch of work i'm
not going to go into details this is my
own particular piece of this and notice
each long where i'm sort of trying to
hang in a little bit of what i got
involved with this is a representation
that i developed along with fernando
flores and others
about the use of commitment the
importance of commitment in getting
tracking things getting them done
completion in in work settings
uh we wrote a book together uh which was
strongly influenced by these guys who
some of you probably recognize uh i will
point out this since danny barbaro is
here that a lot of this got started back
in the
80s or whenever this was maybe even 70s
when we went and he and i and some grad
students went up and had lunch with
dreyfuss and cyril at berkeley and
discuss the issues of what our computer
is really doing um
so
uh interestingly enough fernando is now
we're we're starting on another book
together
he was in the
long story but he was actually in the
national senate of chile for two terms
has finished those terms uh decided he's
had enough of politics
is coming back to this country and we're
going to work on uh another book which
i'll be glad to talk about in
a later thing
okay so worker from the point of view of
the winograd flores book is a source of
commitments
it's
something you can study and i threw in
here management and business as kind of
very broad brush labels if you want to
understand people in the business
context it's not or in that sorry the
work context
it's not about the thoughts per se it's
about the interactions that's the kind
of thing that field gets into
okay so we're going to get a couple more
here
this is a real test anybody recognize
this piece of text
in particular it's formatting
okay this was probably the first if not
the first use of a computer to generate
text in a font that was designed to be
re read as a font as opposed to the
computer font okay this is what's called
the research character generator
which was built apart back in the late
early 70s i think early 70s i think
allen k was the sort of driving force in
it a bunch of other people
chuck thacker bill butler lamson
actually did the technology
but the idea was you would want a
computer that could give you stuff to
read in a way that you made you wanted
made you able to read it well
okay remember again this was not this is
before ebooks this is before kindle this
is just the idea that you have text that
wasn't the thing you were talking to the
computer about
i think that again it seems funny to
think of that as
something interesting but it was
interesting in those days because every
every other computer interaction was
about the thing you and the computer
were
interacting about
so there was a notion that people are
information seekers and producers this
particular
is andreas here
andreas pepke who's here in the info lab
is the one who actually is responsible
for the artwork here which i don't
let him defend but
the what we had here at stanford as one
of a group of projects around the
country it was called digital libraries
and the idea was think about
what's online as a bunch of materials
that you can access and read and share
and use right so you're focusing on the
materials rather than focusing on the
cognition that went into them right or
even the work structure so back in those
days i mean you'll see some interesting
things here like z3950 which most you've
probably never heard of it was a
protocol for exchanging library
information
and
all of the things which we now think of
as being of course that's the web
internet libraries payments interfaces
annotations and so on
all right and
among other things it being a university
we
said let's find some bright students and
let them play around with this stuff
and in particular we had a couple of
bright students named sergey and larry
uh who came up this is actually a page
this is actually what the google
homepage looked like
when it wasn't yet when it was still a
stanford project not a company and uh
you know obviously before it was fully
developed but they said and in a way i
guess this is interesting i'll go back
to my site original about michael about
you know seeing the next generation in a
way they showed us a new world which is
the picture you saw before
was based on a model which said there's
a bunch of highly curated highly
developed things which are available on
computers and we want to integrate those
and they said no let's not worry about
all
you know what is in lexisnexis or that
kind of stuff let's just take anything
that anybody puts on the web and index
all of that
and i think my first reaction and most
people who'd done this kind of
information research was that's a bunch
of junk
you know why do you want to go around
and collect all the junk when you give
we have good well-developed resources
that you could be using
and they said no we want to collect all
the junk right
so
um
they went ahead larry credits me and i
actually i have to disavow this because
i don't remember specifically with
telling him yeah why don't you go ahead
and do this web search thing instead of
some other project he was thinking of
like space tethers or whatever it was
but anyway
it's clear that this whole world
shifted to
thinking about people from the point of
view of how they find and use
information and the computer is a basic
tool for
for that quest there's a bunch of
disciplines that can play a role there
and again i put here just info science
as a broad brush but the obvious point
is that understand that you're
understanding the
nature of the information structure
again going back to park there's been
work on what's called information
foraging and so on about about how you
do that
okay a couple more
this is a really old-timer wouldn't
anybody recognize this probably not
because it's not a famous picture
this is uh this gives it away a little
photo by john coate john coate was one
of the original people who created
something called the well
the whole earth electronic link to give
you the acronym uh and the well was the
beginning of social networking in some
sense yeah well was from today's today's
world a sort of simple bulletin board
you know no interesting technology but
they created a community around it they
had people who had identities on it they
would
enter
discussions people would comment on the
discussions that entire notion that the
computer is providing a
medium for this kind of social
interaction
was started not just by the well there
were some other early bulletin boards
and so on but they really did it what's
interesting is first of all they
developed a community so this actually
is the first annual chile cook-off
that they held f2f as we now say that is
they said this is going to be a
community it's not just a bulletin board
it's a bunch of people who know each
other who like each other john actually
gave a talk in this series
probably 20 years ago 15 years ago
called in keeping on the world on the
well
he saw himself as an innkeeper somebody
who
gave people interesting stuff got them
talking kept out the rowdies you know
and so on
so the well was a
different view of people
uh which today looks like this
okay so you're not supposed to of course
see any detail here this is a social
graph
right it says who you are has to do with
who you connect with
where connecting is what what the well
was all about
so
that says a person is in some sense a
social being again if you want to ask
who are the other disciplines that
are relevant you get into among other
things sociology anthropology right
there's a whole set of issues about
people and how they behave and if you
look at the work in hci today there's a
much bigger component which is based in
the sort of methods and understanding of
these fields than back when it was
mostly cognitive and how does a person
remember things and so on
okay listen actually what's interesting
is this is i don't think he still has a
page like this
uh but he has millions at that time this
is historic because i think there's
something here which says he has 32 000
followers
all right how many followers does ashley
kutcher have now it's got to be well
into the millions right not a question
right
um
so what this says is that there's
something more to social networking than
just being able to get together and chat
you're not getting together with ashton
kutcher and chatting and he doesn't
expect to and doesn't want to
there's a different kind of feeling for
what happens personally to an individual
by virtue of interacting in these
networks i want to take a little detour
to talk about what the meaning of that
is
and i want to take a detour there about
what
i mean by meaning another lesson i
learned from
the work i've done in the d-school which
i'll come back to a bit
um
in understanding people's
needs and needs here in a deeper sense
not just you know i need a pair of
glasses that works and and so on
um
so michael barry has a company called
point forward that does design and one
of his projects which was quite
successful
was he worked for kimberly clark or
whichever the competitor was
and they said we want to redesign
diapers
our competitors are catching up we want
to improve and so on
and the way he describes it he says that
people in the company thought of diapers
as waste disposal bandages and to
improve them you made them more
effective and efficient at waste
disposal right that's the whole point of
having a diaper
he went around and he interviewed talked
to parents in this case you don't talk
to the users directly you talk right to
the although i guess i guess i would say
in this case the users aren't the person
who has the diaper on right it's it's
the parent is the user
and
what he realized is that diapers have a
very different meaning to parents
they're not about waste disposal they're
about growing up
that
when my kid is in diapers i have a
certain feeling about who they are what
they do and when they're when they
graduate to potty training and so i mean
you've all been through this
many of you as parents but i know all of
you at least as
the first time around um
it is a very emotionally loaded topic
right it's not just about okay can we
clear off the poop with the leash terms
right
so he created this whole category called
pull-ups
and the motto for pull-ups somebody
remember
i'm a big kid now
i mean now advertisers are not subtle
notice what this kid is wearing
right the i'm grown up is sort of
carried there as a badge right what you
realize is the meaning of diapers was a
meaning about growing up in a meeting
about kids and adults and so on not a
meaning about what you think a diaper is
about when you just think directly and
that from a commercial point of view
that was a tremendous success
right then all the other manufacturers
imitated them and so on and so on and
now it's it's a whole i don't know the
numbers but if you were in business you
could tell me how many billions of
dollars worth of a category that is and
so on so the point of it is that when
you think of something from a sort of
functional point of view
you're only seeing that side of it
unless you step back and say what is
what is this role as a play in people's
lives what is the meaning to their lives
so let me talk a minute about what are
the different sources of meaning that
people have
okay being grown up is one for kids
so what do people do that matters to
them
or
what are they who how do they identify
what's their identity now identity has
been an issue on the web for sure for
ages a lot of you i'm sure have seen
this cartoon over the years right the
famous on the internet nobody knows
you're a dog
which
plays on this notion of identity which
says that your identity on the internet
is something that isn't your same
physical cognitive and all the stuff you
do because you can create it you can
manage it a lot of you probably read
sherry turkle's books the second self uh
in which she talks about all of the
different ways in which issues of human
identity are played out in this
online world
so personalization
uh is an example of personal identity
who am i how do i project what do you
think i am
you can have artificial identities this
is uh
hatsune miku anybody know hatsune miku
okay the hipsters here do right uh
so this is a famous japanese pop star is
that right
who happens not to be a person
it's a purely online identity but who
does all the things that pop stars do
by being online
uh this is a experiment where they had
kids playing with artificial playmates
so the point is identity individual
identity is
a big piece of this there's also your
social identity and by social identity i
mean who gives you
uh
credit
appreciation
for what you do so this is actually my
daughter's blog site
blogs are a fascinating example of
people putting themselves forward as a
social identity it's not who she is i
mean something you know there's part of
that but it's really am i doing really
interesting stuff that people want to
know about that they'll follow i'll get
a lot of followers i'll get people
interested it's fame and fortune sort of
but in a more personalized way than just
how much money did i make
so i'll put fame and fortune as as the
thing
there's family and friends so a lot of
my identity now that i'm a grandfather
has to do with these two little kids and
third on the way right
um
and
you can read a lot of stuff that comes
out about how
when we really step back and say what's
my identity what's my meaning
those things play a very big role you
know the old line is nobody ever said on
their deathbed gee i wish i'd spent more
time at the office
all right these things are things that
for biological evolutionary reasons are
very important to people and they play
into the computer as well this is a
company that i'm on the advisory board
i've started by a former student here so
a lot of you may know tekobayagas
working on iroom thing i showed you back
there a while back
and there they built an application
which is very simple
a distant grown-up grandparent typically
or absent parent whatever
reads to a child
using a
using two ipads
and they can see each other
they can point and the shadow shows
where the other person's finger is
pointing and say okay it's time for bed
let me read you a book
so you're using the computer to
intermediate this kind of connection
that we think of as being
direct and personal another is that
there's a community in society my
identity to a large extent and
everybody's is
what role am i playing how much am i
helping the world and or the world in
the local sense my church my whatever
the community is
um
i got involved to give my own personal
version of this back many years ago and
something called computer professionals
for social responsibility
uh which had uh
a great slogan i still like technology
is driving the future it's up to us to
do the steering so because of being in
technology myself the community aspect
was how do we integrate these larger
political community concerns with
the development of technology
the past few years and michael mentioned
this i've been involved with what's
called the liberation technologies
program
uh here at stanford where
we have a variety of projects we have
fellows uh this is a fellow you probably
should know his name is evgeny morrisov
and he just wrote a great book called
to was it to
fix everything click here
uh or save everything sorry to save
everything click here
he's a critic of the sort of view that
there are simple tech fixes to
everything
so we've hosted people like him we have
courses where we get people using
new technologies in simple ways that can
improve their lives
did i skip one
no
okay
meaning those are all things that not
all the things those are a list of
things which you might consider and let
me take a step back and say if you're
doing hci which is where this talk was
originated it was for kai
these are things that might guide what's
worth doing what are the things you want
to build you want to what are the things
that are interesting to research
now from the beginning in this program i
always
use the word design you notice a seminar
officially well i don't know what's
official it has two names
all right if you look at the stanford
catalog it is the human computer
interaction seminar and every time
somebody gets up to introduce it i know
you've been continued this tradition
they say welcome to the seminar on
people computers and design which is
what it was originally titled let's
design well the first i mentioned
earlier
this is actually the book that i
referred to by
henry dreyfus
what's interesting about this again is
this is more than half a century old
but tidal is designed for people
so when he was thinking about designing
railway stations or whatever it was the
starting point was what we now call
human-centered design right how do you
think about what it is for people and
what they use
i wrote a book i edited a book had a
great workshop and i say great i mean
they got lots of interesting people to
come
including don and anybody else here who
was at that workshop i don't remember oh
yeah sarah right
back in the early 90s to ask the
question of how
do these
questions about design and bringing
people into design
play on play out in the world of
software and we brought in designers
from all sorts of fields we had type
designers and
mechanical designers and urban designers
because there was a commonality about
the attitude about the posture to
designing
which wasn't specific to any one of
those and the question was how does that
play out in software
um more recently
the design focus that i've had
is due to connections with this fellow
uh now we're out of the gray hair
business right a lot of you know david
kelly uh he's here in the computer in
the mechanical engineering department
and was
a founder of the ideo design firm that's
the best known probably most successful
general
product design consultancy if you want
to call it that
here in palo alto and he and i started
teaching a course together many years
ago in which we got together small teams
of students which included his students
from mechanical design and my students
from cs
and put them to work on simple projects
where you needed to bring both of those
together to build something that would
really be useful that would work for
people and train them in things like
like human centered design
the way that
uh he talks about well i'll talk about
the d-school in a minute but
the way that
we posture this is that students should
be
t-shaped in their skills
that is
depth and that's that list i just put up
for
all of those other things
is what places like stanford are really
great at i know i can look out into a
room here and see people who understand
computer science cold they've taken the
courses they know the stuff they can do
it well and similarly i can find people
in anthropology or in business whatever
it is
what isn't part of the normal university
curriculum is understanding how those
fit together to make real things happen
now i say that a little bit uh be you
know from the past i think that's
becoming more the norm i could argue
that's because of things like the d
school but certainly the classical
academic norm is you get your benefits
by really being the best the deepest in
what you're in
not by
understanding and making it work with
other things so what the d school does
and what the courses that i'm involved
with to do is to say how do you get
students to learn about
design in this integrative sense and the
first principle is you learn by doing
not by talking
so you don't give a bunch of lectures
and you can have a lecture now and then
but you basically get people out there
trying to solve problems which
inherently require multiple perspectives
you can't just pick one from my earlier
list and say that's the one right you
have to say this and this and this are
all things that matter and then you try
you don't just sit back and think about
it and come up with papers about it you
actually go out in the world
build things prototype them see what
happens go back around sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't that's true
of industry too right but the basic idea
is to use that kind of integrative
project as a way to get people to
cross the bar in the t the particular
project i've been working on for the
past few years uh we apply simple um
cell phone based technologies in nairobi
we actually go over there i've been
there a number of times we take students
over for a couple of weeks
they talk to people work closely with
students from the university there
here i think i have a picture
so this is
a mixture of our students and university
of nairobi students and faculty so the
the two guys tall guys there's josh
cohen who teaches here with me and dan
orwa who's in the computer science
faculty there so we work with the
department there uh also very closely
with local
ngos organizations that are actually
doing sanitation or doing health or
doing what they're doing
because part of the principle of course
is you can't
design
in a vacuum you can't say this seems
like a good idea to me why don't they
want to use it
you can people do do that but you
shouldn't right so you have to
understand how do you go about actually
taking advantage of these kinds of
connections
to learn to and that's when you say what
is
design i think it's that insight that
insight about how you integrate
other people and knowing what they want
this is a particular project which just
last night there was an event at the med
school where they had a poster on it
um trying to help people
find clean drinking water in the slums
where there's a small number of water
taps that are sometimes open sometimes
not sometimes clean sometimes not and
using a very simple cell phone exchange
information mechanism
so that instead of walking around for
hours with these cans you hopefully can
go directly to the place that actually
has what you need
okay what is this all and again remember
i gave this talk at the kai conference
to start with
have to do with
the kind of research you might do as a
chi researcher
well one answer is technologies and
although i come from this sort of human
focused human center side
you can't deny that somebody who comes
up with a totally new concept for a
physical device that displays or senses
or whatever
is going to be a contribution
and there are a lot of places where the
contribution isn't how it all fits into
this picture it's the
step back from that here's a here's a
gizmo you can try see what you can do
with it so i think there's still a wide
range of fascinating questions
in what kinds of physical devices what
kind of technologies are going to shape
the next round just as the phone iphone
shaped this round and so on
another is to do research on these human
sciences so i made that long list
everything from linguistics and
anthropology and business and so on and
i think there is room in all of those to
say let's do research
about what happens when you bring in
technologies so it's not just general
linguistics or general
management theory but what is the
overlap between that and the
technologies
interaction mechanisms have been the
sort of mainstay of kai if you go to the
kai conference for those of you who
still have the option of going and
aren't there already it's in paris
starting this weekend
and
great place to go in the springtime
a lot of what you see there is
a finer grained as what
to use thomas kuhn normal science right
that is if you have the idea of using a
mouse to point to a screen how can you
point better
all right if you have the idea of typing
words on a keyboard is this thing called
swipe going to let you
much more quickly do stuff on your phone
than if you have to type one key at a
time and so on and that's perfectly
valid research i mean i think some
people feel well that's just a waste of
time it's not the
big picture stuff but it certainly is a
valid part of any science to say let's
take the things we basically understand
and go deeper let's understand exactly
how to make them work better exactly
where the parameters are so that's
another realm the harder part is
design there's sort of a quandary as to
what constitutes design research design
practices is
much more straightforward
so i'll switch the question for that how
do you think about designing your own
research and this is the preachy part
but let me just take a minute to end
with this
one answer which came from going back to
the working of the florist and so on got
this fancy word from philosophers called
ontology and ontological it's used in
many different ways but
basically what that means is
start by thinking about what are the
basic underlying issues you're dealing
with not the surface stuff
what is it about
why why is it valuable
another sort of general thing is
always be challenging your assumptions
right this is advice to not just young
researchers but all of us it's very easy
to get locked into saying well how do i
do x better instead of should i be on
the x at all
and a lot of success in the design
methods are things like idea they always
talk about the fact if somebody comes in
and says can you help us with our
improve our toaster
they say well why do you want to why do
you want a warm bread
right and maybe the answer is you have a
good answer to that you do you know
improve the toaster but it leads you you
always want to step back as well as
forward
um
the open opportunities again this is so
trite it's
uh
useless to say but i think it's
something that people in academic
research don't aren't quite as open to
as people who go into business i'm
always impressed by the fact that the
people i know who've gone off to start
some kind of a startup business
often end up doing something which if
you would ask them at the beginning they
would have said no no that's not what
i'm doing
right it's called pivoting right if
you're in the business school it says oh
i got out there what i realized is this
thing i thought i was doing isn't really
what's needed
but this one is
and i think in academics we tend to be
more locked in we write proposals you
have to you know also it's a whole
structure which makes it harder to say i
see a new opportunity here which isn't
what i thought i was doing
and let me go do it
so hopefully we can get some of that
spirit into the academics and then the
bottom one which is from that discussion
on meaning is
look for the ways in which what you're
doing whether it's social networks or
you know glasses whatever it is
fits into the way that people want to
lead their lives and what means
something to them
having used up almost all of my time
i will take questions
so
this is not a question for terry but
this is something about gary so stories
are great things
uh
i just looked remember that slide of the
info bus
well part of that big picture is online
digital archives
and so this is from the
uh fighting mountain digital archive at
the stanford library
uh dated may 5th
1977 so that means that at least half
the people in the room were not born
then
dear dean rhoden dean of
humanities and sciences with pride and
enthusiasm the computer science
department nominates professor terry
winograd for your dean's award for
distinguished teaching in humanities and
sciences
and then it lists a whole bunch of
reasons
things he did
as you probably have heard through your
informal channels winograd's brilliance
as a lecturer is now well known
throughout the university his courses on
computational linguistics are quote star
attractions unquote and his seminars on
advanced technical issues are usually
filled overflowing in addition he is
much sought after as a program and
thesis advisor by our students he
carries a much heavier advising load
than the average faculty member in our
department
two of his graduate
student thesis students will graduate
this year
uh etc etc goes on like that but i just
thought you'd like to hear that thank
you and for those
for those who don't know
while we're in history mode ed phi
gumbaum was
among other things in me a couple of
points really one of the founders of the
artificial intelligence
program
guidance here and the person who invited
me to come
so
that's uh
yeah
um
that was an absolutely fabulous talk i
mean
literally advances seem to be
experimental engineering rather than the
theory
do you i mean do you think there is some
point in the future i mean people like
donald trump
i don't know
um but we're listening to all the nice
examples i mean they were they had real
elements of serendipity or opportunism
do you think there was some point in the
future where
computer human interaction work will we
have a genuine theoretical base so
that's not a two-minute question or even
a zero minute question uh but let me say
a word about theory i mean theory is one
of those loaded words that means very
different things different people go
over to the comparative literature
department here and ask them what they
call theory and you will not get
something that you would be happy with
if you went to the chemistry department
right so there's a version of theory
which is a kind of predictive
quantifiable theory which is what the
hard sciences have developed and used
over the years which says if you have
the right theory you can predict so in
the case of a computer you might say
this interface will work and that one
won't
and we can give you logical theoretical
reasons why not that approach has was
pushed very hard by
newell simon card moran i mean a whole
bunch of people back focused at park but
not just a park
30 years ago is that the right amount
something something on that schedule uh
and i think it had limited but
interesting results i mean if you say is
that a big influence not really but it's
it's still around
i look at theory as including what i
call orienting theories so an orienting
theory is not something that gives you
answers it gives you questions
so you say if i take this theoretical
stance it's going to make me ask about
something and when i ask about that that
may guide what i try in experimental
engineering
and so things like the whole philosophy
hermeneutics i mean the stuff that i
wrote on floors and so on i would say
falls in that kind of theory and i would
say the humanities people think more
that way the theory is a framework that
leads you in certain directions it isn't
a mechanism that you can crank to get
answers out
and my own view is that the theories
that are going to continue to have value
primarily are more of that kind than of
the you know physic you know
mechanical engineering physics kind
which tells you this bridge is going to
collapse if the stress is more than
point three
that's the
point they the way you're oriented
actually lead you to ask different
questions yeah so then many of the
theoretical perspectives of proposing
were not
sort of from our own uh academic
pedigree in a sense we drew on them and
i think to our own strength that we did
so um and yeah i feel like we often
critique ourselves as being somewhat a
theoretical as a result do you
do you think that we should be pushing
harder on creating those kinds of
theories that we can use to build up our
own
future work or is this something where
we'll continue to get more leverage out
of drawing on others i think my sense is
that it's the leverage is in
shifting and transforming rather than
creating separately so if you say what
are the kinds of theories take the
obvious example what are the kind of
theories that sociologists try to make
about social behavior
those are tremendously affected by the
fact that we have social networks
because they have different creates
different phenomena those phenomena call
for different kinds of explanations the
theories themselves may end up being
social theories they aren't hci theories
but the whole point of what those
theories are about is part of what we're
creating
yeah bob here's your invitation to
speculate about the future
of
hci in 10 years 20 years
and you can answer it in any way you
choose
well 18 years 10 years or 20 years is um
you know we're not talking 100 said 100
i would say brain interfaces whatever
who knows
i don't really know um
the obvious trends are going to continue
so the notion that a computing device
includes what's in my pocket and it
includes what's strapped to my wrist and
it includes what's in my heart monitor
and so on is going to grow and grow and
grow we will no longer
as and this is again something wiser
said
30 years ago will no longer think of a
computer as this thing you go up to it's
just part of the world it's part of the
environment where they're ubiquitous uh
invisible so that's going to happen
along with that there will be a lot of
applications
which uh require interfaces that are for
example integrating that information i
think the whole quote big data world
nice thing about big data is you can
have all sorts of things the problem
with it is one of the problems is that
it's oops
when you close this it doesn't actually
go off
uh
oh well um
that
uh is very hard to make use of it's very
hard to make sense of so i think this
whole world of sense-making
to put in that it includes things like
visualization and graphics uh which jeff
hare works on it includes uh things like
having ways to trigger
the
awareness of events other than just
somebody says do this now i think
there's i think there's a bunch of
things in again dealing with let me call
it attention and awareness
we all agree there's plenty of
information that's not a problem the
problem is attention
um how do we how do we focus that how do
we manage it
uh there's a whole set of issues going
back to this social political side that
i think are going to come up and be very
interesting and problematic for research
around things like privacy
and you see it happening now with the
google glass right there's this cool
thing and i can wear it and i can go
around and i can
display the weather and who you are and
whatever it is i can also take pictures
of everything i see
uh this whole recent thing in boston was
an example where the fact there's a
benefit to the fact you can take
pictures of everything you see uh but
there's a flip side there's a downside
and i think a lot of the stuff that's
going on in social networks as well as
things like ubiquitous devices
at some point we're going to get a
couple of serious uh oh that shouldn't
have happened
and then that will cause rethinking and
new research on how do you
how do you get the benefits without
having that that happen
yeah
one question i think related to theory
and related also to the future is what's
driving the progress the h the c or the
eye
and i think for the early part of the
work it was through the technology where
the computers we're driving i see your
work it's trying to put the emphasis on
the eye
and and making progress that way so you
might be dreaming about technologies
that don't exist
and thinking about the human and how it
might go so could you say something
about that and kind of what are the
drivers
who will progress
i'm
focused on the age myself right i think
as i say technology is going to progress
there's no way that what we have
physically as technologies is just is
the end limit uh it may saturate in a
sense i mean you know there are a
certain number of form factors that work
with people going back to dreyfus
and you know other form factors are just
useless if they don't integrate with
people but you know organic displays and
flexible lists and all that kind of
stuff
you never know some particular
new technology in those could drive a
whole new field
but i'm not sure that
interaction i guess i was putting in
there as a way of talking about how
people relate to it other than the human
centered design so in some sense i'm
being unfair
by
distinguishing interaction and design
and giving interaction all the dull
stuff
so i would say it's it's the human
centered design side what are the things
people want to do and how do you support
those
you